You've just wrote a program that prints out Eliza's to do this, and it probably
looks somewhat like this. A counter starts at 1, it goes up to 6, we do some
work, we increment the counter, keep on doing, until the counter. Has reached
its end. There's nothing wrong with it. But if you think about it, the three
statements that control the counter. The initialization, the check, and the
update. They're spread all over the loop. The for loop is there, to organize
it a bit more neatly. Here is the basic outline of the for loop. It has three
slots. And, we fill in the right statements, in each one of them. And I'll
demonstrate that. In this low tech way. We'll cut out the initialization, the
condition, and the update, and we'll put them in the right slot. Initialization
goes here. The condition goes here. And the update goes here. Now, you see,
they're all neatly together in the hetero of the four loop. Let's have a quick
look at the control flow. We start with the initialization. Then we check the
condition. We go into the inside of the loop. Then we do the update. Now, the
counter is 2. We check the condition. We go into the inside of the loop. We do
the update. Now, the counter is 3. We check the condition. We go inside the
loop. We do with the update, we check the condition, we go and set the loop. Do
with the update, check the condition, go inside the loop, through the update.
And eventually, the condition is false, and we leave the loop. Notice that the
initialization happens once, the check happens before entering the loop, and
the update happens after finishing an iteration of the loop.